I was going to say for you like I think
like there's a lot of misconceptions
about Adam but I think one of the main
things that people will talk about is
how like for whatever reason he's
extremely infatuated with gang culture
yeah and if you look at the previous
regime of co-hosts and the new regime of
co-hosts
it's Crips yeah yeah he [__] with the
Crips I guess the narrative about Adam
is like hey he's infatuated with you
know black violence gang culture this
that and the fourth but then like you'll
realize like Adam I think it's just
really like a very curious dude who's
just like a true content creator so like
you know these are the people he's
around and what like I don't feel like
he like purposely sought brick baby out
because you were a [__]
who you say what no add I'm to my Adam
oh he's about the misperceptions of Adam
oh yeah nah no me and me and me and Adam
being cool since like
2015. because I think people are like yo
okay ADT left and he just went and got
more Crips but me and dub like dub is
like an honorary crib he all he does is
hanging with the Christmas
wedding yeah so
uh
he's always been cool with dub and the
people that dub break around and the
fact that me and Doug have like a great
relationship that's how we even got
closer than what we you know I'm saying
when we first met whatever it was so
uh when I came home I came I did the
interview I could pop back up I did an
interview then I started like being on
YouTube but I didn't really understand
so I started reaching out like hey how
dude he's like you should come on yeah
like and we'd start going into
hey I feel like I'm ready to I mean hop
on camera like [__] well you guys
already having those conversations prior
to 80 leaving yeah we was already I was
already damn near
coming in yeah yeah because 80 was there
right 80 was there like multiple times
when I was coming up there like for like
news and different little [__] like that
so I didn't even see because I don't go
home like this [__] tires you out
sometimes to where I don't go home and
watch the [__] we were doing yeah
and then I go back and and go watch it
you hear what I'm saying so even if like
I just seen 80 Adam so when I was seeing
the the headlines and all that [__] like
somebody leaving or whatever I'm like
yeah
I don't really want to get into the [__]
that's going on right you know I mean
the mess because it's like gossip you
know what I'm saying because if it's not
coming to my phone directly I'm not
really so I'm like I was paying no
attention to it then when they start
being everywhere I'm like oh wait that
ain't no click bait type [__] you get
what I'm saying like if that's how slow
I am when I'm first coming in I'm like I
don't know I'm thinking they trying to
get the numbers up or something so now
I'm seeing Oh it's less than this that
and I'm like oh
is going down in this [__] like
I'm texting Gina Gina trying to hold it
stand their ground and then she go that
was a wild that was a extremely wild
um
extremely Wild
couple of days because I
got uh
hit up by Adam to come and fill in for
Lush or fill in for whoever
not knowing that he had just fired Lush
and
so I called ad and
and I know Adam called me and told me
what happened with Lesh and he was like
I need somebody tomorrow to be on the
show so I called A.D and I was like yo
uh what's the deal you know like
he's like yo do it there tomorrow he's
like he's like I think he's like I'm
about to leave oh [__] yeah cause I I
didn't talk to A.D about it but I
already know what his response was going
to be to me because we already was there
so right and then what do I I don't have
a job y'all leaving with like I'm just
getting you everybody's like oh you
stayed or you was with no jumper after
that so what who was offering me a spot
where they're at where who did I leave
from yeah you were already I'm not a
part of that crew that makes sense I was
gonna say uh recently you guys
interviewed the gay [__] guy
which uh was extremely interesting
to say the least I just liked sharp just
in the corner just like what the [__]
happening not sharply said some [__]
where he was like you know DP would he
educated the dude who what a DP was he's
like not getting your whole [__]
blown out by a bunch of n-words I was
like oh my God
but I was gonna say like when you do an
interview like that do you hear about
that from like your like big homies like
yo what are you doing yeah they but no
all right so the big Hobbies was mad but
they thought I was stamping
homie yeah the whole time I'm like
letting him get his [__] up and telling
him like
nah we ain't going for that well he also
clearly isn't a [__] yeah he's remover
or whatever he's doing this and like how
are you a gang member you don't know
what a DP is that's what I'm saying is
is it's like you guys were educating him
yeah that's what I'm telling I'm like
the lack of knowledge like bro you don't
know what that is that you said that you
from so that's why I told him like all
throughout the interview then at the end
I really taught him like
they gotta watch it man they gotta watch
it because the whole interview ain't now
he keep on serving ClickBank I mean uh
clip after clip he does you know what he
does but once the whole interview drops
oh interview Drive you'll see what's
going on I'm definitely not stamping no
gay [__] and he's from over we don't
really like yeah I mean like I'm not
gonna keep on saying that because but at
the same time I can't believe it even in
politics why I can't eat politic on him
I can't give him a DP beat him up or
nothing because he's not just a crazy
movie that goes yeah I mean that [__]
crazy they got a deal I just saw the
clip and it was so funny uh shout out to
[__] Mack who's one of the most widely
entertained human beings that's ever
walked the face of this Earth uh